hey book with that hate you mentioned  was there a point really early in your  career started your career when you kind  of realized not to take any of that  stuff seriously especially with  something like this when even you  yourself are not taking this seriously  and then people are taking it seriously  if you get what i mean  yeah yeah i'ma sound off on the  situation i just talk about putting  things in perspective  you know i'm really enjoying this and i  always have enjoy social media and  you know i check it daily and  you know when they're saying good things  about me i don't get too high i don't  get too low on it  only problem i have  is people still comparing me to kobe  bryant when i told them in the playoffs  stop bringing up mama mentality  i'm inspired by kobe bryant and my  mentality but i am not kobe bryant  and  people are out here yelling mama  mentality from the mama's house  i'll leave you with that  thanks buck